I'm speaking today with Agnes Heller a
Jewish Hungarian philosopher about
persecution escape and freedom welcome
miss hello thank you I also welcome you
ladies and gentlemen to the interview on
DW my name is Thomas pond miss Hilary
you escaped the holocaust on more than
one occasion yet you have repeatedly
said I never let myself be forced to do
anything I never felt unfree not even
when I was supposed to be shot when you
said that were you thinking of your
escape on the Danube River that is an
exaggeration exaggeration of course I
did not feel free during the time of the
Holocaust certainly I did not feel free
as I stood by the Danube and waited to
be shot I did not feel free I was always
convinced that I have a choice that is
not the same thing
one does not have to feel free to still
believe don't to be certain that it
makes a difference whether you walk on
the left side of the street or the right
whether I jump for don't jump nice we
knew nothing we knew nothing about
Auschwitz we didn't know about the gas
chambers why was I so absolutely
convinced that they would kill us if we
go there to where they were bringing us
I don't know that was instinct there are
good instincts that is an erroneous
construct that we always choose
consciously we do not always make a
conscious choice you're talking about an
inner freedom that if something your
father was no longer afforded he was
murdered in oceans outfits was liberated
seventy years ago we were commemorating
that liberation this year what is your
father's legacy my father was a moralist
he was a very strict
morale person which is why he left a
great impression on me he helped
refugees he went to the internment camp
in Madonna Street in order to help the
young people and not so young people
there who had fled first from Germany
and then from Austria later also from
Poland he wanted to help them Poland
flutist and in helping connect Hungarian
Prime Minister Viktor Orban said about
the situation today we do not want any
foreigners here we do not want refugees
many Hungarians are saying those things
our Hungarians bad people a nation
people individual people are bad or good
evil or good a nation can be neither
evil nor good but there can be
governments like the one in Hungary that
facilitate the worst instincts of its
population or Bonn is a person and our
government consists of people who toy
with the worst instincts of the
Hungarian people who amplify them visa
view the good instincts and what happens
the nationalism of the 20th century as
perhaps of the 21st century is I'd like
to say well the most potent poison is
substantive nationalism and that is
Orban's policy he talks of defending the
nation-state against the European Union
against Brussels we have to rein in the
nation-state that does not mean he
always says that Nations that states are
like egotistical animals and he's right
about that a nation-state is much more
egotistical than all other forms of
state it is an egotistical animal that's
how he actually expressed himself that
there will be a new period in Brussels
an end to liberalism we will put an end
to liberalism
he said just days ago that is his
program and it is a very strong program
as you had said there are people there
are leaders party leaders who agree with
this program today
let's take Poland or marilla pan and
France and other countries what is all
that meeting that candy you be saved
know what it means I can only describe
it
this type of substantive nationalism has
grown quite strong the people seem to
have forgotten that nationalism since it
was victorious in World War 1 against
the cosmopolitan and the proletarian
internationalism bestowed us with some
60 years of mass murder and 100 million
dead bodies and if you forget the 100
million dead bodies the whole thing will
begin again
you've emigrated from Hungary before
because he wanted to flee persecution by
the communists at the time that's become
so bad again that you may have to leave
again soon those times cannot be
compared Hungary has been sharply
criticized and rightly so but you can't
compare or bond with Brezhnev you
compare him with Democratic leaders like
on America and if you compare him with
Angela Merkel immediately see that
within the European Union or bonds
so-called illiberal democracy symbolizes
and embodies the worst of all possible
options what can philosophy do to help
make clear to people that nationalism
will lead to catastrophe philosophy
itself does nothing it is the
Philosopher's that can do something
philosophers can do two things they can
act
citizens of a state among other citizens
not because we are philosophers but
because we are citizens of course they
can express their philosophical
perspectives to the people in the
newspapers the press and on television
that is philosophers can behave like
businessmen we have a product this
product we believe the truth is our
product we're not quite certain but we
believe that it is true this product the
truth is what we are selling let's talk
about the product philosophy if many say
philosophy is aloof that it is not
something that has any bearing in
everyday practical life let's dispel
that what's a good person come in
firstly what is practical life that's
where one should begin they say you
can't make any money with philosophy
that is probably true working in the
economy you could make a whole lot more
money philosophy was never an occupation
where people would get very rich but
other not from your rich experience as a
philosopher any Maxim's that you have
worked out in order to answer the most
fundamental questions the question for
example who was a good person what must
he or she do philosophers have asked
fundamental questions who is a good
person what is being what is truth what
is life very many questions many of
these questions have had a direct
influence on human existence that is
whether we live more or less meaningful
lives but not all of these questions
also have a direct influence on
political thought some of the questions
posed have an influence on political
thought I must say philosophers have
always been in love with politics from
Plato to Sartre and high
and not always in a positive way perhaps
even in the worst way were they always
in love with politics they always had
the idea they must tell us something new
and true about politics that has always
been a let's call it a passion of
philosophy you named a number of
philosophers not a single woman there
are not many women in philosophy I could
name Hannah Arendt of course she was an
especially political philosopher yes why
is it that there are not many well-known
women in philosophy is it the women or
is it the other philosophers poor
philosophy as for culture in general you
need freedom in all of our history women
have never been free at least not in the
sense of independence they were always
dependent on others and if you are not
free if you are not in a sense
independent then your thoughts and
capacities cannot develop freely you
cannot then create anything in high
culture that is why women have not
achieved anything in high culture it is
different today today women can achieve
something in high culture and it is
because they can be independent because
they are not oppressed that is the case
today you're a free independent woman
and have been for many years actually
since childhood
you're now 86 years old you commute
between homes in New York and Budapest
you hold readings like here at home book
and you write books
you speak of writing as an erotic
experience let us take part in your
pleasure what is it about writing you
find erotic of course it is erotic one
loves doing it you feel good when you
are writing reading and writing that is
anything you do that brings pleasure
where you feel pleasure for which you
have a passion can be described as you
brought it
and I believe that philosophy for me at
least is erotic that's how it is Heller
we always conclude our interview with
three incomplete sentences and ask our
guests to complete them the first
sentence is I go swimming every morning
because because I love it I like to do
it I'm not a feminist because because
I'm not one I don't believe in isms all
isms just demand something of me that I
do not want to do that is independence
and isms just don't go together that's
the greatest fortune of my life is to
have been born I had no cellar thank you
for speaking with us thank you